[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace andino desde
Colombia en esta ocasión hablaremos de
los primeros 100 días de la presidencia
de Gustavo Petro y junto a Luis
Guillermo Vélez analizaremos los logros
hasta el momento y los retos que aún
enfrenta
[Música]
los progresos de Petro desde que llegó a
la presidencia van desde lo económico
hasta lo social Las alianzas alcanzadas
en el congreso con los liberales los
partidos de centro y su gran bancada de
la coalición pacto histórico le han dado
el apoyo para comenzar a aprobar leyes
uno de los primeros logros y que podría
ser el más importante es la reforma
tributaria con la que pretende recaudar
20 billones de pesos colombianos unos 4
mil millones de dólares para financiar
programas sociales está el acuerdo de
compra de tres millones de hectáreas de
tierra de ganaderos para entregarlas a
campesinos Por otra parte logró la firma
de la ley Paz total con la que busca
dialogar y poner fin a años de conflicto
no solo con la guerrilla del Ln sino con
todos los grupos al margen de la ley en
temas internacionales abrió de nuevo la
frontera entre Colombia y Venezuela que
estuvo cerrada desde 2015 y recuperación
de las relaciones matemáticas entre
ambos países y tras varios periodos
legislativos aprobaron finalmente en el
congreso el acuerdo de escazú que
establece protocolos para la protección
del medio ambiente en América Latina y
el Caribe la presidencia de Gustavo
Petro es la primera de izquierda en los
200 años que lleva la República enfrenta
desafíos tanto estructurales como
políticos ya que tiene una fuerte
oposición Petro llegó al poder con el
50,44% de los votos en un país
polarizado Luis Guillermo Vélez abogado
ex secretario de la presidencia del
gobierno de Juan Manuel Santos tiene una
visión crítica sobre la actual gobierno
pero reconocen que hay aciertos han sido
hábiles en armar una coalición bastante
grande Aparentemente sólida y han
priorizado la agenda gubernamental han
presentado una reforma tributaria una
reforma fiscal muy extensa Yo creo que
es una reforma antiempresa pero pues es
la reforma que ellos querían y habían
hecho a probar y han planteado el tema
de la paz Total que es un proceso de paz
con una cantidad de actores armados que
hay en el país esa priorización las ha
permitido avanzar en su agenda y han
dejado parte de esa agenda para el
próximo semestre una reforma
Aparentemente al sistema de salud una
reforma el sistema pensional y otro tipo
de reformas entonces esa priorización Y
esa coalición los ha hecho efectivos del
punto de vista político según la
encuestadora invamer la gestión del
presidente es aprobada por el
49,7%. y su desaprobación es del
42,7%. estas cifras contrastan con las
de la encuestadora Centro Nacional de
consultoría que dice que el 61% de los
encuestados aprueba en su gestión
mientras el 23% estaría en contra de sus
políticas cifras superiores a las del
anterior mandatario Iván Duque quien en
los primeros 100 días tuvo una
aprobación del 23%. los grandes desafíos
que su administración son los problemas
económicos también la elevada inflación
que podría llegar a final de año al 13%.
la más alta de los últimos 20 años
sumado a esto el discurso de los
hidrocarburos en el que propone el fin
de la exploración petrolera en momentos
en que la economía colombiana depende de
los ingresos de la venta de petróleo
además sus ministros han enviado
mensajes contradictorios lo que aumenta
la incertidumbre en sus políticas Luis
Guillermo Vélez analiza Estos factores
Pues el precio del dólar es un síntoma y
no es causado por factores externos como
dice el gobierno como ha hecho el
presidente el el precio del dólar está
mostrando el malestar la enfermedad que
tiene la economía colombiana hay una
desconfianza en la economía la gente
está sacando el dinero de una manera muy
muy importante
hay 121 billones de pesos en tes en
deuda pública colombiana comprada por
algunos importantes jugadores
financieros extranjeros donde esas
personas pierdan confianza o acaban de
perder confianza en el actual gobierno
tendríamos en frente una debacle
económica y el gobierno y el presidente
en particular no ha mandado las señales
de confianza adecuadas la principal
fuente de recursos Fiscales del gobierno
colombiano
viene de los hidrocarburos de la
explotación de petróleo de gas y de
Carbón la compañía de petróleos Estatal
colombiana ecopetrol ha perdido algo así
como
Diez mil millones de dólares de valor o
sea es una pérdida valor de la empresa
Estatal de petróleo es muy grande que es
del Gobierno Entonces yo creo que ese
tipo de reforma anti empresa no va a
llevar a los recaudos que ellos están
planteando
Gustavo Petro un ex guerrillero de
izquierda recibió un país con una crisis
económica galopante tras la pandemia y
que esa grabada por la guerra en Ucrania
con este panorama y Con vientos a favor
y en contra aún le falta implementar el
acuerdo de paz de 2016 con las Farc y
emprender una reforma agraria
su presidencia aún comienza Y son muchos
los retos y promesas de campaña que aún
debe cumplir los esperamos en otra
entrega de enlace andino sigan con más
información en Francia 24 y France
24.com